hi I'm Neil Patterson and today we
wanted to update you on the earthquakes
that affected tens of Miles along the
city of Turkey border
[Music]
in southern turkey buildings crumble
like sand
obliterated by some of the worst
earthquakes in a century
we aren't no more than a month on from
the natural disaster in which tens of
thousands of people lost their lives but
for those who survived the aftershocks
aren't just measured on the Richter
Scale the crew
I think
in Turkey more than a million and a half
living in the disaster zone are still
Without Shelter
in Syria where Civil War has raged for
years Aid was slow to arrive cholera was
not
and as always it is the children who
suffer most
[Music]
they'll be our focus on this edition of
The Daily
you see these images on TV before you
come out here and you see the level of
Destruction and you think well that must
be one area one street one road and as
we were driving into antakia in hakai
you realize that it is block after block
after block do English works with UNICEF
the United Nations agency that focuses
on humanitarian Aid to Children he has
spent the past three weeks working
between turkey and Syria and honestly I
you know I've been doing this job for
for five years I've been all around the
world and I have never seen anything
like it it knocks me sideways and it's
hard to imagine how anyone honestly
survived tell me exactly what you saw
then Joe buildings just completely
flattened pancakes
um buildings ripped in half you know we
visited one school where the entire rear
of the school was gone so you walked
into classrooms and they were just open
to Rubble for about as far as you could
see the city is I I was there three
years ago for work and I saw it and it's
a beautiful city and it is a diverse
City
and it's hard to see how
families will be able to move back in in
the near term you speak to families and
they have no idea how they're going to
be able to to rebuild their lives in in
the short term at all
um you know it is just about survival in
the in the days and weeks ahead before I
think they even have the the headspace
to begin to contemplate what comes next
when you see that the rebuilding is it
seems a distant Prospect to you is is
that just because of the skill of the
destruction or because of the location
in which you you were the the
difficulties in getting the materials
that you would need to put this place
back on its feet I think is the scale of
the destruction there are many many many
homes that had completely destroyed
there are many more that are damaged but
families are terrified about the idea of
going back to these homes even to try
and go and Salvage some of their
belongings because aftershocks continue
you know we all of us here have have an
app on our phone that gives us a
notification anytime there's an
Aftershock and some of them you know 4.2
4.4 you you may barely notice but we
have you know 5.2 just a few days ago
and and that you know that gave me pause
for thought I was I was just getting up
and and
it's scary and so for children who have
been through this who went through the
first two catastrophic earthquakes
you know were then bought from their
homes a week later two more so you can
just imagine how this compounds these
distressing experiences and leaves
children just completely on edge
completely unable to to focus anything
beyond
you know did this fear of is my world
going to be turned upside down again
tell me about some of the children that
you met because of course you know the
parents the mothers the fathers those
that were lucky enough to survive you
know their their priority is is keeping
their child Alive food Water Shelter
there can't be a lot of living on top of
that no completely and turning to Syria
um
engineeris you know we I was there just
yesterday and the city has a much
um lower profile in terms of the height
of the buildings compared to Antarctica
but the damage to the buildings that
were there was just as severe but the
reality is is that many families in
Syria aren't living in buildings
especially in the Northwest area they're
living in tents because they have been
displaced not once or twice but multiple
times by the conflict we're now
approaching 12 years of conflict there
was one young boy I was speaking to
earlier this week called Majid and he
was nine years old
and his entire childhood nine years has
been spent set against this backdrop of
air strikes and displacement and once
again being forced from his own once
again his his mum having to explain to
him why they can't stay where they are
you know and so for children like magic
this is just the latest catastrophe and
you know we always say that children are
resilient but we have to give them the
tools to be resilient we have to give
them the space to feel safe and feel
secure in themselves and in their lives
for that resilience to have any effect
whatsoever
I mean presumably some of these children
have have not just spent you know recent
times in these tents they have spent
large parts of their life their entire
lives for many of them it is hard to see
how these children are going to be able
to to not only rebuild their lives but
their communities see ultimately once
there is hopefully at some point
peaceful solution in Syria this is the
generation of children who are going to
have to rebuild the country and when I
was speaking to Majid and his younger
brother uh Bara like I was asking them
what they wanted to do when they grow up
and Majid said that he wanted to be a
doctor and Bara said he wanted to be an
engineer and I thought that's a such a
specific
um you know dream of for a child but
then you look around you and you think
they want to be able to help the people
that they see every day they want to be
doctors so that they can you know help
heal people who are injured whether it's
by the earthquake or by the conflict
they want to be Engineers because you
know they've seen their cities destroyed
over and over again whether it's by
fighting in the conflict or by you know
these these kind of horrific natural
disasters and you know children often
see the world around them and
focus on how they could make it more
to to you know something that would
offer a a better future for them and so
I think that's what these children are
doing and we have to as the
International Community be providing
them with the ability to do that and
that means education it means you know
safe places to live and and to exist
um you know otherwise
there's there's very little hope
has there been any assistance from the
Syrian government the Syrian regime
itself we work in all areas of Syria and
we work with everyone that we have to in
terms of reaching children my focus
whilst I've been here has been the
situation in the Northwest
um and now obviously the vast majority
of international support and
humanitarian Aid has been coming in
across from the Turkish side from the
from the border but you know we've been
doing this for a long time we know how
to do this we had even before the
earthquake thankfully supplies
pre-positioned over six million dollars
worth of supplies including supplies to
get to ensure that people can get access
to Safe Drinking Water hygiene supplies
highly nutritious biscuits for children
but you know we know that the needs are
huge and whilst trucks of humanitarian
AIDS is getting in
we know that we need more and I suppose
also the problem for you your colleagues
is the fact that you know in the
aftermath of a natural disaster like
this
unsanitary conditions dysentery cholera
these are all entirely predictable
outcomes
they are indeed you know and it is a sad
irony that you know you can speak to a
child who has lived through 12 years of
war for catastrophic earthquakes tens of
thousands of aftershocks
and the thing which could be the biggest
risk to them right now is a glass of
water this is is just beyond belief you
know and so getting in providing that
water at the moment we're Trucking water
into many communities which is hugely
expensive and can only be a short-term
measure but we're also working with the
authorities to to repair Water Systems
so that there is a long-term more
sustainable solution but we we only have
this access into Northwest Syria for a
short period of time at the moment we
hope that it will be extended because we
can't help families rebuild their lives
in the next couple of months you know it
is going to be a long-term effort where
do you think the northwest of city will
be a month from now where of course a
month on from from the Quakes themselves
and but from what you're saying pretty
much where they are now
you know families that are resilient
they have gotten used to having to to
survive often you know in in these
difficult circumstances prior to the
earthquake there was a feeling that the
world had forgotten about Syria but if
we can ensure that this does not leave
people's minds that people continue to
to talk about this work to to donate to
the organization to the doing this
incredible work to put pressure on on
their politicians to continue supporting
this work then hopefully we will not be
in a situation in a month from now or a
year from now where the world has moved
on once again
so what then does the world need to do
ah it starts with with funding certainly
you know times are tough around the
world but but that support and that
flexible long-term support is is
critical
um but we also know the power of of
activism and advocacy and speaking up
and raising awareness you know and that
is something that we can all do is to
when you see these pictures on the news
or when you hear these reports on on the
radio is speak to your friends about it
speak to your family about it you know
because the more awareness there is of
this situation I think the more empathy
and Humanity exists and I think that
grows I think I really do I think the
more we tell these stories the more we
hear these voices our ability to to
responding kind increases with it
Joe you've been to places like this
before I know if when I ask you you know
a month on from these earthquakes when I
mentioned Northwest Syria when I
mentioned turkey where does your mind go
to what incident to what individuals
I would like to see children back in
school as soon as possible in Turkey it
was incredible the authorities have have
built playgrounds in every single one of
these camps you know so the kids have
somewhere to be on a slide or swings
um but getting them back into school is
critical because that gives them that
hope for the future that gives them that
sense that there is something better
coming down the road yeah and this is
not an easy task especially in Syria you
know a large number of children were not
in school before the earthquake and now
we have that additional challenge of
further displacement
um but if we can do that if we can be
providing them with these spaces and
with school books and with supplies and
with teachers then we're giving them the
tools to to create the better life for
themselves
Joe I have to ask this I how do you get
through days like the one you've just
had how do you do the job that you do
because it's not just focusing on on
dealing with you know
the massive human cost of these natural
disasters you're very much focused on
the children and as soon as my mind
starts to go in that direction do you
know what I I will freely admit I find
my eyes well enough yeah no I know I
know that feeling well
um
seeing the difference that the work
makes
um you know seeing
how happy
effectively for for a short moment a
child can be when you give them these
pens and papers and and they feel safe
and secure you know that is it but also
it's you know it's it's a privilege
honestly so much of this work is a
privilege because
we're getting to you know do what I
think anyone would love to do which is
hopefully make children's lives a little
bit better in in the most difficult of
times
my thanks to Jewel and of course to you
for listening to this guy News Daily
with me Neil Patterson this Edition was
produced by Emery Woodhouse with Alex
Eden our editor is Philly Bond